We're progressing toward
the learning health system.
As a result of the federal efforts
we'll discuss in lesson two,
electronic record adoption
levels are very high.
And the focus is now shifting
to the next challenge,
the inability of the hundreds
of systems in use to share data.
The term for this is interoperability.
And we'll discuss it in
more detail in lesson 5B.
We'll place particular
emphasis on a new approach
that is rapidly gaining traction, and
that appears to provide a long-sought
practical solution to interoperability.
It's called Fast Healthcare
Interoperability Resources, or
FHIR, F-H-I-R.
Through FHIR, access is provided by
web services such as rest API's.
And health care data is packaged
in the JSON or XML formats.
Or to use widely on the internet and
by other industries.